she's really funny and amazing and it's
just magical she you know she everything
she touches Alex Rodriguez gushing like
never before
about his leading lady Jennifer Lopez
I've learned so much from her in such a
short period of time
my daughter's lover she's a great role
model she's a Latina woman or both born
in this great city of New York and it's
fun to give back et caught up with the
former baseball pro in New York Tuesday
at a Kia event
he says it's JLo's generous heart that
he loved most she always wants to give
back to the community and you know those
cars sing alongs the famous couple loves
to share on social media
[Music]
Alex let us in on the secrets behind
those videos you know when I'm in the
car with Jennifer I just try I just say
I do as I'm told you know I'm hate it's
like when I'm with my daughter the same
thing they just say daddy do I play this
and yeah there's not much to say between
us we have a lot of talent I just stay
out of the way and let her do all the
work and speaking of talent
check out this adorable video of JLo
coaching a ROG's daughter Ella Alexander
on her vocals presenter Frankie said
that she's very good
my girls adore Jennifer she's she's a
great role model and you know they they
want to do exactly what Jennifer does
right did she wouldn't they want to sing
they want to dance they want to produce
they went direct you know a lot of
people don't know she's also great
athlete and a great business person and
for me I'm the luckiest father in the
world to be able to you know expose my
beautiful daughters to someone as
brilliant as Jennifer
[Music]